everybody kind of knows the rules of
brainstorm you get four or five people
together you can't break by the way you
can't brainstorm with 20 people
everybody has to be able to see each
other it's kind of think of it I think
of brainstorming like a jazz ensemble
maybe you're gonna have a trio a quartet
a quintet maybe pass that you can't play
jazz it's just too complicated so many
people so they get together and they
often you know come up with a question
and they brainstorm for a while and they
go great that was fantastic and then
there's all these post-its or all these
notes on a whiteboard and somebody says
I'll take a picture they take a picture
with their cell phone and then and
that's my my edges that's where ideas go
to die
I just just go to die on cell phones
somebody's got a picture and they all
walk away and and then I asked them well
what happened I said what we had a
brainstorm and I said well what's the
result they said well I had a lot of
ideas and we're you know what are you
gonna do with it and they haven't really
made it actionable so here's the thing
brainstorming works great for coming up
with lots of ideas and very diverse
ideas particularly if you have a really
good jazz team it can really you know
play off of each other but you know at
the end of a good brainstorm when we run
it at the d.school there'll be 150 you
know post-its on the board but but
that's not the end because you haven't
really done anything generating the
ideas is relatively simple once you get
good at it figuring out what you're
gonna do with the idea is putting them
into sort of buckets often ideas are
clustered around certain themes so the
first thing we do and we the reason we
use the post-its is then we stop you so
get the brain storms over we're gonna
now we're gonna do a little bit of
evaluation a little bit of what we call
naming and framing the ideas we're and
put them into the clike this cluster is
all around one thing this cluster is all
around another thing this is these are
all wild cars they don't cluster at all
which kind of move the post-its around
and then we try to give them we try to
you know put the buckets or sub buckets
into some kind of a framework and we
just give it a name and the funny or the
name of the better these are the crazy
grandmother ideas these are the ideas
you know if if you know if ducks could
you know fly or if chickens could fly
this is what the ideas would be so we
give them funny names but it's it the
idea
to sort of bring them back down into
reality and put them into some kind of
framework because at the end of my
brainstorms if you ask somebody what
happened they say we had 150 ideas
turns out they were in about six
different categories and we when then we
rank the top ideas in each category and
we have seven ideas we would really like
to build a prototype of because we think
these seven ideas ask the most
interesting questions around the problem
or the space that we're doing it
same thing with life does that when we
when you finish with your outta C plans
we say find four or five things on the
Odyssey plans you want a brainstorm
because it's something you're curious
about it just discovered hey maybe I
want to be a real estate developer or
maybe I want to figure out what it's
like to make you know gourmet you know
cupcakes at a cupcake store so you've
got these ideas now you brainstorm all
the different ways just you could create
a prototype around those ideas and then
you name those bring them back out of
crazy land into something that's
actually real and then you have
something that you can work with so at
the end of my brainstorms people
literally will say I got you know 110
ideas and five categories down to six
top top ideas we're gonna build four
prototypes
that's an actionable brainstorm and and
then you do the prototypes and you get
some new data and the world tells you
something that you didn't know and then
you get to brainstorm again but bringing
something just for its own sake is kind
of a misunderstanding of the process now
a lot of times people also have trouble
with the notion of wild ideas why do you
have to have crazy ideas because you
know no one's gonna use the idea you
know well what if there was no gravity
how would we solve this problem and
that's one of the prompts I throw when
people are stuck I give them promising
what if you were an elephant how would
you do this how would you use a mouse if
you were an elephant how would you how
would you do this if there was no
gravity and they have some crazy crazy
idea the problem is our brains want to
cluster ideas very tightly around some
core central thing and no matter how
many times we brainstorm if we don't
change the parameter of that thing we'll
get ideas that are roughly clustered
around the same thing
to make these big conceptual leaves to
start a new a new cluster a new center
of ideas you really need to kind of
break out of your SATA
your box and the only way to do that is
to come up with something that's so
stupid
it makes no sense at all and then you
have a bunch of ideas there and then you
have a bunch of ideas there and like I
just there you can always bring the wild
idea back an example we did we did a
sort of an example brainstorm and this
isn't probably the way it worked but you
know for a while people are trying to
figure out how do you solve poverty in
India and the idea was well we'll give
money to rich people though they have
companies they'll employ people there'll
be a trickle-down effect and poor people
will eventually get saved and people
have been doing that for a long time and
nobody didn't work then a crazy guy
named 100 Muhammad Yunus said what if we
give money to people who have nothing
but give money to people so poor they
probably can't pay it back
and that's microlending now I mean his
idea wasn't to give it to people who
can't pay it back but his the big shift
was instead of this trickle-down thing
what if we just give this woman $50 and
she runs a cell phone service in her
village and that lifts her out of
poverty and allows her to hire five
other people to do cell phone service it
was a completely radical idea that came
from come up ending the whole model
right that you give money to the top of
the pyramid and that trickles down and
as I do it's now let's just flip that we
have money to the bottom of the pyramid
and it'll trickle out that's been one of
the most successful innovations right in
in poverty reduction and in finance so
it's things like that where you really
need a brand new idea that requires the
wild idea to get it started and then you
can always bring it back and find ways
to make it implementable